j'ai cru comprendre mais là il a pris la
grippe il a plutôt eu la grappe soit
vous fatiguez comme ça de leurs pertes
et son nom de famille mais c'était pas
non non je verrai vous avez vu en douce
g j'ai fait plaisir tout ce que je peux
dire les américains dans lequel on t'a
dit donc tout va bien vous avez une
aventure 7 millions par une aventure se
bat comme ça qu'on dise que vous vous
savez c'est tout ces aventures séquences
et plus d'un quart d'heure rien n'y a
fait passer une bonne soirée avec une
personne de compagnie et une bonne nuit
ni faire ça sans aviser leur faire
offense à prénommer j'ai encore encore
naples il a pas du tout quand l'appli
encore pour trouver d'écho park avec sa
marque ou d'un produit tout est parfois
trop par moi même
non pas du tout non c'est une personne
que je connaissais kennedy n'est pas
pour une fois qu'une personne que vous
connaissez de venir chez vous on était
venu des personnes étaient venues guinée
oui ok pas grand chose à la télé c'est
plutôt rare lundi soir on fait un film
là il m'a dit bayrou reste juste des
fermiers
du coup il a dérapé voilà mais dérape
écouter alors il papa non papa ou sortez